[Music]
a few days ago the dc
fandom was hosted as a kind of virtual
comic con which could be followed
comfortably from home the live viewers
were offered a really exciting program
with a lot of news for example the first
footage of the batman and the trailer of
zack snyder's legendary snyder cut were
shown
in the following we would like to
summarize the most important highlights
of the fandom so that you can stay
up to date with your upcoming dc
favorite movies as well
on the one hand there are news about the
flash with ezramilla which has been
promised for
years fans were already afraid that the
production would now come to a complete
standstill were proven wrong
director andrew muscati and others
involved presented a few updates so the
flash will be a groundbreaking film at
dc
will play a crucial role in its creation
those responsible have a kind of
multiverse concept in mind in which
among other things
different batman versions could co-exist
similar to flashpoint in the comics
different characters with different
storylines can collide and open the door
to new stories thus the also announced
appearance of ben affleck as batman in
the flesh makes sense
the flash is scheduled for release in
u.s cinemas on june 2nd
2022 wonder woman 1984
also had an important new revelation in
a trailer the new villain cheetah can
now be seen for the first time
nevertheless many fans still ask
themselves how director patty jenkins
will approach
the time jump to 1984 which is already
anchored in the title
in addition to galagadot chris pine will
also return to the camera as steve
trevor
newcomers are kristen weak as cheetah
and pedro pascal as maxwell lord the
release date of wonder woman 1984
is october 2nd 2020 unfortunately no
trailer was released for the next panel
but at least other footage was included
and of course we're talking about james
guns
this suicide squad for which among other
things an epic behind the scene video
was released
furthermore all characters of the movie
were officially unveiled for the first
time
after it was already clear that margot
robbie is harley quinn and joel kenneman
as rick flack would return
the other actors were also fully
revealed including john cena's
peacemaker
pete davidson as blackguard and idris
alba as bloodsport
by the way james gunn also posted a
poster for the suicide squad on twitter
where many protagonists can be seen in a
kind of 70s world war ii
scenery the official cinema release of
the suicide squad is on august 6th
2021 another highlight of the fandom was
the first trailer for zack snyder's
justice league which was mentioned at
the beginning
besides the elaborate trailer it was
also announced that justice league will
be released in four one hour parts
first on hbo max and then as a complete
work the snyder card will have a similar
structure to the movie version but
snyder promises
a completely new experience both in
terms of plot
and design it'll be exciting to see what
path snyder's cut will take and whether
it'll result in a new trilogy together
with man of steel and batman vs superman
we'll know more next year when justice
league will be released in the usa on
hbo max
what the international release will look
like is still unknown
the absolute highlight of the dc fandom
however was not one of the previously
mentioned films but rather the first
teaser trailer from mad reefs the batman
because it left a lasting impression on
fans and critics alike
from the summer portrayal of the riddler
the collaboration of the gotham pd and
the still a virginally decorated batcave
characters like catwoman and the penguin
were also spotlighted
all in all a coherent trailer with an
ending that definitely makes you want
more
the expected release date of the batman
is october 1st 2021
did you follow the dc fandom live and if
so what was your impression
feel free to write it in the comments in
two of the three movies of the star wars
trilogy hayden christensen plays anakin
skywalker
although his popularity among fans was
not really high at the time
this has changed in the meantime with
the animated clone wars series
as it is reported now christiansen is
supposed to join the cast in the new
obi-wan series next to the already
confirmed
you and mcgregor and return to the role
of anakin
and darth vader if you believe some fan
theories this series could show a series
of flashbacks to important scenes from
the clone wars because their anakin and
obi-wan fight side by side
of course we are still talking about
purely speculative statements at this
point
but in our opinion there could
definitely be something to it
by the way the obi-wan series will be
exclusively released on disney plus in
2022
the upcoming disney movie raya and the
last dragon is the first of its kind
because at least at the beginning it was
produced solely through zoom and home
office
responsible for this is winnie pooh
director don hall who in his opinion
produces the most
beautiful animated film he's ever seen
now her first cgi picture of raya and
her faithful companion tuktuk appeared
the disney adventure revolves around the
world created by dragons in which the
warrior raya and her gang of other
underdogs want to find the last living
dragon
of course there's a reason for all of
this because this is the only way to
save the kingdom of kumandra from
destruction
among others star wars actress kelly
murray tran plays raya and rapper
akrafina plays the dragon zizu
raya and the last dragon will be
released in new cinemas on the 12th of
march
2021 for quite some time now there have
been rumors that netflix is working on a
resident evil series
on thursday the rumor was finally
confirmed on a twitter post which was
accompanied by some introductory words
among other things the wesker kids were
mentioned who will move into raccoon
city and might uncover secrets
one thing is clear the series will deal
with two different periods
on the one hand with the 14 year old
wesker sisters who reveal secrets and on
the other hand the time a decade later
when the globe is plagued by monsters
infected with the t
virus here the 30 year old jade will be
in the center of attention
and you can also look forward to the
unveiling of some of her secrets
but rather regarding jade's family and
herself as you can see the basic plot
will of course again be about zombies
and showrunner andrew depp promises that
there will be something for every
resident evil fan and also for newcomers
to the franchise
there's no exact date for the broadcast
on netflix yet but we will keep you
informed
as always with the haunting of hill
house netflix provided us with one of
the scariest horror series of the last
years the announcement that the second
season would follow
is now more than one and a half year old
and really not much has happened in the
meantime
but now this season with the haunting of
bly manor even gets its own name
and new faces as you can see on the
already published photos
this means that the two seasons are not
or only sporadically connected to each
other like in
american horror story and therefore
stand for themselves according to
entertainment weekly there will be a
multi-year contract between netflix and
series makers mike flanagan and trevor
macy which most likely also means that
after season 2
there will be no end the haunting of
blind manor is based on the 1898 novella
the turn of the screw and revolves
around two orphans
miles and flora who are raised by young
governess at bligh manor
there will be a reunion from season one
however as actress victoria pedretti
who played now crane will slip into the
role of danny clayton in the future
in addition to news about the cast and
the story there will also be a first
spooky poster which will give us a
foretaste of the second season that will
be released in fall
[Music]
so